hey guys my name is Jess McDowell
today's a night the March and you're
tuned into gamespot news first up today
GTA 5 heists are just a day away so
whether you're keen on the idea or not
here's a bunch of info the update which
will be introducing heists to GTA online
maybe four point eight gigabytes
according to a Twitter user who received
a prompt to download the update early
for Xbox one so GTA 5 owners can look
forward to that whether they want to
play online or not in addition to Heist
the update will also come packed with
new pvp mode daily objectives as new
free room activities Xbox achievements
of nine new achievements you can nab for
doing all kinds of clever things in the
mode the details on the update and the
achievements check out our story on
gamespot it seems of the original
version of DMC Devil May Cry may have
been a little too suggestive sensitive
elva have removed a particularly saucy
line of dialogue from the upcoming
definitive edition developer ninja
theory said they altered the cinematic
to improve pacing and to take out the
super suggestive line arted by Lilith
the demon mistress of the main
antagonist mundus the scene in question
has mundus laying out his plans for
world domination and if you're after the
nitty-gritty specifics you can check out
the exact wording of the removed
dialogue on gamespot Ninja Theory
insists that it was more amazing issue
than anything else and that there are
far more suggestive scenes throughout
the rest of the game so I guess there's
that to look forward to DMC Devil May
Cry definitive edition comes out
tomorrow for Xbox one and ps4 finally
today the gaming world has resolution
fever again as the resolution for
battlefield hardline has been confirmed
just like Battlefield 4 hard line will
be 900p on ps4 and 720p on xbox one
presumably in order to ensure both
versions can attain 60 frames per second
Visceral Games confirm the resolution
detailed
today as always hard line on PC will run
however you damn well like provided you
have the gear the game is out on March
17 from microsoft and sony's last and
current-gen platforms as well as pc let
me know down in the comments how you
feel about battlefield hardlines
resolutions you can have the game spot
where we've got used on you drive pub
dlc and apples $10,000 wat that is it
for me today but i'll be back same time
tomorrow with a bunch warned you so be
sure to check back with me then